how did you get into like uh doing
impressions like you know you're on jay
leno on uh pam and tommy right you know
then you know you you're doing dr phil
you're doing all this playing vince
mcmahon on young vince mcmahon on young
rock i mean were these something as a
young young kid you were doing
impressions yes like what was yours what
are your top impressions as a kid well i
remember i went to this like jesus
christ water sports camp with my
spit tech i was the only jew there which
the guy tried to convert me to it was my
buddies from high school they were in a
uh uh uh church group and they took a
summer
it was a camp for like 10 days it was
water sports camp so from 7am to like
four was like on the beach jet skiing
[ __ ] brilliant boobs and brilliant
and just and
and uh boats and just
basketball just fun in the sun water
sports and then
come back
dinner and then we all break off into
groups and i always respect yeah call
let's go back to the tent and then i was
like no come come hang with the group
you know and so then i'd sit in the
group and he'd be and then he'd take me
off to the side a few times ago
so
are you are you tied to
are you tied to judaism and i go yeah i
got a bar mitzvah you know so i'm pretty
i'm pretty doubted at this point but i
did too but i just did it for the money
yeah did you really i mean i didn't
though
you know
no i mean i got so much but i'm not
religious at all you know i mean yeah
i'm very reformed
and so i'm like yeah man it's it is
where it is i think it's you know i'm
just here for the good times i'm
circumcised man i'm not going anywhere
dude i had to show it to him to prove it
and um
and then i was like uh
i was like uh well let me go to the i'll
sit down and like participate
did that then they had a talent show
this is what i'm building to so that
talent show and i came up with this idea
for my buddies where i would do all
these voices and they would like lip
sync all these things so i basically
wrote our whole sketch and it was me
doing the voice i did at that time were
ready i did a bill clinton
i did a kermit the frog i did a mike
tyson i did a um
schwarzenegger and uh cosby and splinter
from ninja turtles wow by the way put
all those guys in a [ __ ] reality show
house
and see who comes out on top
that's amazing so it'd be like you know
be like splinter would be like you know
you know
doing something then and then kermit the
frog and then and then bill clinton you
know and then mike tyson you know and
then and then bill god we will come
through with a carpet going to sleep you
know and then um
yeah
people loved it ate it up they were like
this jews got it that's what probably
triggered you like i got to do stand-up
i got to do
stuff like that but again it was all for
shits and giggles but it was like too
but it was a fun thing to
they all looked to me being like hey
funny friend like what should we do for
the skit and i just was like hell yeah i
was like wow and so i wrote a whole
thing and we you know get ever everybody
had a script and then uh
so that was cool but and then doing
impressions of teachers and friends at
school and then like did you audition
for jay leno for yeah
so my agent hit me up and said do you
have a jay leno and i was like i had
done a couple of videos uh as him
did you have to audition yeah
so did you get dressed up i uh no but i
sent a video that i had where a friend
did like a pretty decent chin and makeup
so they could see a little bit of that
because i saw the one that recently
posted with uh it's you talking to david
letterman
oh yeah it looks like both of you you're
leno and la he's letterman oh bro that's
incredible that's incredible if you go
on his instagram instagram adam
raycomedy right but jeff richards who
was on snl mad tv does an amazing
letterman and a slew of other incredible
impressions and he does this now thing
for his podcast where he has people come
on and he does an impression and then
they do one or he interviews like he he
interviewed bill burr as louis anderson
but he does the deep fake
like when we they record it on some
program and the guy spends time to
really do it i didn't realize how good
it was gonna look yeah it looks [ __ ]
incredible yeah like yeah it looks like
it's leno and letterman